>> Dude: Grrr!
Something is really wrong with this!
>> Sally: What are you playing with?
>> Dude: I downloaded an
app called "Part Palette."
It lets me plan genetic circuits
using Parts from the Registry.
>> Sally: That sounds great.
Can I see?
>> Dude: I can select parts and then
wrap them together on the palette.
Or at least I'm suppose to be able to do that!
00:00:24,866 --> 00:00:24,356
I keep getting an error message.
>> Sally: Hmmm...
maybe the app doesn't work,
or maybe there's something
about the parts you're trying to wrap together.
What gene are you trying to build?
>> Dude: I just grabbed these 3 parts to try.
>> Sally: A terminator, an
operator and an open reading frame?
That's not a gene...
>> Dude: but it's got an open
reading frame...what more do I need?
>> Sally: Walk with me Dude.
For starters you'll need a promoter.
That's a snippet of DNA that the RNA polymerase
binds to when it starts transcription.
Promoters come in different
strengths so choose carefully.
>> Dude: How do I know if a
promoter is strong or weak?
>> Sally: Well the strongest
promoters have this DNA sequence.
RNA polymerase can bind these bases well.
The more bases that are different from this
consensus sequence, the weaker the promoter is
since RNA polymerase will bind less well
and transcribe less often...at least...
that's how it usually works.
>> Dude: oh no!
I hear an exception coming...
>> Sally: Well sure Dude...it's
very clever really.
There are promoters that are used
in different stages of cell growth
and those promoters bind a
slightly different RNA polymerase
so they have a consensus sequence
that's a little different from this one.
And then there are still other
promoters that have lots of differences
from this consensus sequence but
they are still strong promoters
since they also have DNA sequences
nearby that bind activating proteins.
The activators help RNA polymerase
find the promoter
and that gets transcription really cranking.
Activated promoters can be very strong.
>> Dude: When does it end!?!
>> Sally: Another great question
Dude!...there are sequences that come
after the open reading frame called terminators.
These tell RNA polymerase to stop
transcribing RNA and to leave the DNA.
These terminators are really useful if you
have another promoter downstream of this gene.
You'll need a terminator if you
don't want the polymerase to read
through this gene into the next one downstream.
>> Dude: "Downstream?"
Don't you mean "on the right?"
>> Sally: Cells don't know their
right from their left so we have
to use the natural polarity of double
stranded DNA when we give directions.
"Downstream" means "more 3-prime" no matter
which strand of the DNA you're working on.
>> Dude: So in this app I can wrap any promoter,
ORF and terminator together,
and I've got a gene!
>> Sally: Well actually you've
got a transcription unit,
and most of the time you'll want to translate
the RNA from that unit into a protein.
To translate it, you'll need to
include a ribosome binding site.
The RBS is where ribosomes
attach to the RNA message
so they can start linking the specified
amino acids into a protein chain.
And you can control the strength of the RBS to
control how much of the message gets translated.
>> Dude: and I'll bet there's
an app for that too...
>> Sally: well if you're
interested in working on one,
let me tell you about how genes are arranged in
eukaryotic cells like plants, yeast and human...
>> Dude: Can we do that another day Sally?
My disk space nearly full.